[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et vous me permets permettrait d'y
associer mon collègue de l'ardèche
jacques genest lundi 11 novembre à 11h52
un séisme de magnitude 5,4 a frappé le
département de l'ardèche
plus généralement la vallée du rhône et
nombre de communes et singulièrement la
commune du teil
nous adressons à cet instant toutes nos
pensées et notre soutien à l'ensemble
des personnes qui ont été blessées ou
qui ont connu des dégâts assez
importants
le bilan de ce séisme est aussi lourd
qu'inhabituel dans l'hexagone en effet
environ 300 bâtiments endommagés
une trentaine détruit des établissements
scolaires fermés et certains de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore aujourd'hui
hébergée dans l'urgence dans certains
gymnase de la commune à cette heure
monsieur le premier ministre les
ardéchoises et les ardéchois et j'y
associe aussi certains collègues drômois
attendent des réponses de la part de
l'état s'agissant tout d'abord des
établissements aidés centrale nucléaire
de cruas et du tricastin
l'institut de la radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire a indiqué ne pas avoir
constaté de dégâts visibles sur les
installations mais continue ses
investigations pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
avez à cette heure des informations
complémentaires
ma seconde question porte sur les
mesures d'urgence et sur la solidarité
nationale que nous appelons de nos voeux
confirmez-vous la prise rapide d'un
décret de catastrophe naturelle et en
attendant le processus d'expertisé et
d'indemnisation des assurances quels
sont les moyens financiers d'urgence que
laon l'état entend mettre en oeuvre pour
venir en aide aux populations touchées
je vous remercie